last men on earth your co-star Kristen
Charles she was on the show not long ago
and she said that you guys shoot last
men on earth on this on a set that's
right next to a dildo factory she said
this on the air and there's a lot of
discussion about it and I guess the
dildo factory found out that Kristen
Kristen had mentioned them on the air
and so they invited you guys over for a
tour yeah we we got a call from from
pipe dreams which is the name of the
company and they invited all of and this
is real they're right next door D
absolutely real this is it's not right
next door it's one block over okay um
actually it is right next door because
it's a multi I like there are several
buildings yeah yeah yeah build oh yeah
yeah yeah one one main long building and
then two buildings off
you got to know if you're flying over
you got to know your Luna yeah we go
over there and there is it like if it is
just you know you just like I I just
feel like dildos just exists they just
like you don't really you just think
like dildos just magically appear and
then you go over there and you're really
hot shrooms they don't grow in the for
exactly but they have to be they have to
be manufactured by someone you never
think about I never thought about that
it's a like you know okay Hannah skip
over what I was just about to say there
but like you go in there and there's
there it's like every detail there's a
person who who pours the latex into the
into the mold dildo shaped yeah into the
mold and then they you know dump it into
this is this big person who's got in
charge of like cooling them down and
then there you know these a very nice
group of ladies who paint veins Oh
faint painters I mean it's it's that
much attention it's handcrafted is what
you're saying
it's an eulerian ever made in America
that's America
it's impressive it you know there it's a
it's a you know a real business but I
mean it's it's did you feel weird you
took your whole staff over there we took
the whole staff which I thought was a
great idea at first and then you you'd
like as we went through there were a
couple things like they showed us this I
don't even know if I can describe it
I'll say it very slowly so you can beep
it out if possible it's like the video
of a woman having her vagina molded
you're not what are you doing that for
your beard is covering everything they
showed a video of a woman having her
vagina molded vagina molded I've never
even heard of that well you gotta go on
this tour
no I dunno first time that I thought
like it first it's like oh this won't be
a playful tour and then I was like okay
this is a human-resources disaster this
is like this is a lawsuit this is
multiple multiple multiple lawsuits yeah
did you did they give you something when
you visit a factory I know when I was a
kid and I visited the Wonder Bread
factory when I was leaving they gave me
a loaf of Wonder Bread this was in the
Boston area growing up when you leave a
dildo factory you get any freebies you
get like hey you know here's I got one
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they gave us all loads of Wonder Bread
[Laughter]
they hooked us up to say the least I got
this enormous box of stuff that I then
put in my car as I said I've been so
busy it's just still there in my car and
like I do not valet park anymore I'd
like Street Park everywhere because it's
like this you know like there's this a
bunch of dildos and stuff and then
there's this it's actually really cool
it's this it's like a miniature water
cooler it looks exactly like a big water
cooler but miniaturized and it's filled
with with Lube like personal okay which
I have not used well why would you and I
are that to be cold no no it's not in
fact a container and you keep that over
the bed it's as as cold as where it's
stored probably right it just it looks
like a water cooler so you can talk to
your office mates around it yeah but so
that's popping out the top of the thing
and there there were some nipple clamps
in there that's all either you brought a
picture of you trying the nipple clamps
on did you like them
crazy it look like one maples on the
telephone talking to the other hey you
I'm over here on the right you gotta
come on over sometimes very painful very
painful but that's a the point of a
nipple clamp I guess I brought you a
gift from there from what's it called -
right thank you so much that's my
favorite Christmas carol tastic thank
you very much no idea what this is I'm
guessing this is a paperback book yeah
we will take it's coming out of the
paper
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll take a much-needed break Oh turns
off hand Oh solar-powered we'll take a
break we'll be back more with Will Forte
in just a second
[Applause]